[Musique]
les expériences de fusée et se
poursuivre sous la direction du devin
plombier or le professeur charcot qui
était au goal peu comme on le sait
criaient à travers les barreaux qu'il
avait une idée géniale
le chef shadoks l'osi sortir et dit
qu'il s'occuperait de la fusée en
étroite collaboration avec le plombier
la concurrence se disait-il les stimuler
et nuit pendant ce temps là il pourrait
retourner se coucher
le devin plombier et se servaient
exclusivement dans ses expériences
scientifiques de son robinet magique et
quand la terre était d'un côté lui avec
son robinet il la voyait pas rond et et
il disait que la fusée il fallait donc
bien la faire monter
certes ajouté t-il on risquait de
retomber où l'on était mais ça valait
quand même la peine d'essayer
je le connais ta télescope tellement usé
peu quand on regarder trop loin avec les
rayons se cassaient de sorte que lui
qu'il voyait la terre par rabat et il
disait que la fusée il suffisait
simplement de la les six premières
certes à tous et ils ont risqué de ne
pas aller exactement là où l'on voulait
ou d'aller là où ne voulait pas mais on
était sûr au moins de ne pas revenir
foule au net et com justement la fusée
ne voulait pas beau ça prouvait bien que
c'était son clan à lui qui était le nom
[Musique]
lequel des deux avait raison